in this situation you're not saying
there's not a call there's not a meeting
there's not a memorandum there's not any
unspoken rule that i'm telling cam hey
can you whisper
whisper to charles that hey he needs to
lose or she needs to lose or he needs to
is that's not taking place in a box it
doesn't have to take place
it's unspoken they know they all know it
okay so when did you
go and flip from just being somebody
that could read the fighters and pick
them well
when did you flip and saying maybe how
to think about you know
fixing these fights and get involved in
that how did that transition take place
when i started spending my own money
okay because
no matter what happens to your fighter
you're spending your money
and obviously it's to your advantage
well i was going to say to your
advantage that your
fighter win and that's true most of the
time it's not true all of the time
but it's true most of the time and well
i'll
we can get to that why why it's not
always true um
but you i realized that first
i was wasting time you know
by even you know i was picking i was
picking correctly almost all the time
because i know the business and i know
fighting but
especially with heavyweights things can
happen guys bang their heads
they you know um they get hit to the
body with a shot that you know
there are contingency things that you
can't predict
and i thought this is crazy if this
other guy's going to lose anyway
why should he have to battle my guy for
seven or eight rounds and really get
kicked around
when i can say to him you don't have to
do this
you're going to lose anyway i guarantee
you're going to lose anyway but you're
going to get hurt
but we can go home early fourth round
third round fifth round yeah
whatever you work out and you can work
out
you know there can be incredible
specific
specificity at times so if you like this
sort of short clip from an interview i
did click over here to watch the entire
interview and please don't forget to
subscribe to the channel take care
everybody bye